la bombe est lâchée l'ambassadeur
américain s'est même dit prêt à parier
sur sa vie selon lui l'Afrique du Sud a
fourni un soutien militaire à la Russie
dans la guerre en Ukraine au même moment
le président Rama posa est en pleine
séance au Parlement il a été sommet de
s'expliquer
monsieur le Président pouvez-vous nous
confirmer si les armes de guerre ont été
chargées à bord d'un navire russe avant
qu'il ne quitte le cap
vous êtes si désireux de savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé
la question oui la question est examinée
et en temps voulu en temps voulu nous
serons en mesure d'en parler
l'effet remonte à descendre 2022 des
armes et des munitions auraient été
chargées à bord de ce cargo russe
amarrer près du cap puis le navire le
Lady hair aurait ensuite quitté
l'Afrique du Sud pour la Russie des
manoeuvres qui vont alors contre du
statut neutre de Prétoria en février
2022 le pays avait refusé de condamner
l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous avons été
très clairs et n'avons pas mâché nos
mots à propos de tout pays qui prendrait
des mesures pour soutenir la guerre
illégale et brutale de la Russie en
Ukraine
dans la soirée Pretoria a dép le manque
de preuves c'est du déçu de l'attitude
publique de l'ambassadeur américain mais
s'est engagé à ouvrir une enquête
indépendante